thank you everyone for attending today's
local energy showcase
i hope you have had
i found this day interesting and have
answered some of your questions
i believe there is a large conference
taking place in 11 or so days
however
we are
we are
ahead
and hands-on
on this showcase
and a first for suffolk
i would also like to give a huge thank
you
to our sponsors
who
or they are
university of suffolk
essex eastern new energy
triple bottom accounting
maple cone zenergy
poli polar solar
chronos
technology and of course baba and
mid-suffolk building control
and b e a b e e a angler
not only for their commitment to
addressing the issues
of climate change
but also for making today's event
possible
also to our wonderful speakers
who helped put into perspective the
importance of green energy and
sustainability
as well of course to tell you
our guests who have helped make this
event a success
we've discussed a range of topics
and welcome expert speakers
heard from real life case studies and
taking part in workshops
to find out how we can benefit from
local energy for a bite of brighter
future
i hope you can come away from today's
event
with some valuable knowledge on how you
can make an important change by
committing to the county wide aim in
becoming carbon neutral
with the net zero in practice
and paths to zero carbon pat
carbon panel session we have had some
in-depth discussions
and answers
that can give us the confidence to put
these ideas into practice
before too long we will see a positive
impact
from the discussions
we make today
babel and mid-suffolk district councils
have stated our commitment to make
suffolk carbon neutral and to continue
down the road
the path of sustainability
this is not a one-time fix
and then return to the old ways
those are behind us now
and moving forward we are all taking
great steps in making our aims a reality
your attendance here today
has proved that reducing the impact of
climate change
is an important issue for businesses
today
and we are incredibly grateful to
everyone
here who is doing their best to embrace
new energy solutions by moving forward
to a brighter greener future
thank you again to everyone
who made this
this possible today
let's turn today's knowledge into
practical solutions
and take a leap forward to our cube our
carbon neutral lives
and i would also like to thank
worsted park for the wonderful venue of
today's meeting and obviously tomorrow's
as well thank you
[Applause]
well that concludes proceedings thank
you very much indeed for turning out um
i've very much hope you've enjoyed today
i most certainly have it's been a
pleasure being here and i wish you a
safe journey home thank you very much